I believe we want to pass this report to
the Danish presidency with a good will
that they will have all the support
necessary to proceed in a timely way
with this most extremely difficult
portfolio and I hope that they will have
the same support as we have had from you
during our presidency in this work to be
very much look forward to continuing
this established working methods with
the incoming Danish presidency of the
council in order to make a good progress
in the first half of 2012 as we move out
of the exploratory phase into the more
detailed negotiations there seems to be
broad agreement on adopting short
procedural conclusions on the mff later
this week at the European Council we
appreciate this since the conclusions
will give us a clear mandate to bring
negotiations forward doing the Danish
presidency in order to pave the way for
the final deal hopefully at the European
Council in the second half of 2012 let
me conclude by saying that I am very
heartened by the support and the trust
that you have all said you have in the
upcoming Danish presidency it is no
secret that this is a tough job and
we're going to need all the support and
all the friends we can get to make sure
that we can make the progress that we
want to do we can have as many meetings
as everybody wants but if there is no
will to move forward then it will be in
weight therefore we ask not only for
your support and your trust but also for
your cooperation and we are looking
forward to that well colleagues I think
that this debate shows that there are
not too many happy people around this
room I guess if I ask the Polish
delegation whether they would well if
they were allowed to speak they would
say they also unhappy
so this is exactly the way it should be
i have and i think this report is giving
quite a good balance of what we have
been discussing for the last few months
and we hand it over to our danish
friends and we wish them of course a lot
of good luck